[Musique]
bonsoir heureux de vous retrouver pour
ce nouveau numéro de 7,8 des invités
voici le sommaire
le paquet neutre est obligatoire depuis
ce dimanche désormais plus de logos ou
de design mais simplement un paquet
uniforme
nous ferons un point avec le docteur
camille car trop de l'hôpital mignot à
versailles
et puis nous recevrons aussi frederick
henderson coach sportif saint quentinois
qui nous donnera des conseils detox pour
bien débuter l'année
depuis ce dimanche le paquet neutre est
obligatoire fini les paquets de
cigarettes avec les logos maintenant
vous aurez droit simplement à un paquet
uniforme avec des images chocs
le but lutter contre le marketing des
sociétés de tabac et réduire la
consommation
alors cela marche-t-il pour en parler
nous recevons le docteur christine qu'un
nul car trop responsable de l'unité
d'addictologie à l'hôpital mignot à
versailles bonsoir bonsoir c'est
efficace
l'australie est le premier pays à avoir
appliqué cette mesure il ya eu plus
d'une soixantaine d'études qui ont été
publiés dans des revues internationales
qui montrent l'efficacité
essentiellement sur la cible des jeunes
ça diminue effectivement le nombre
d'initiation au tabac ça diminue le
nombre de fumeurs
ça diminue aussi le nombre de cigarettes
fumées
ça incite à l'arrêt et effectivement ce
côté marketing qui était aussi très
ciblées vers les jeunes est complètement
annie les concernant les fumeurs plus
anciens qui sont très dépendants tabac
la mesure est probablement insuffisante
pas d'impact majeur parce que il ya un
mécanisme qui s'installe et de
dépendance au tabac qui est importante
et qui va probablement empêché ces
fumeurs la de diminuer ou les aider à
arrêter de fumer il faut d'autres
mesures qui soient alors je vois que
vous êtes d'accord avec cette mesure
je vous laisse écouter jean françois
vigouroux président de la chambre
syndicale des buralistes des yvelines a
priori lui il est contre nous n'étions
pour le paquet neutre
nous sommes pour toujours la santé
publique
mais je pense que le paquet européen
aurait été largement suffisant mais il
ne faudra pas très longtemps pour
s'apercevoir que ça n'influence pas sur
les ventes
alors vous comprenez son avis mais pour
lui ça n'aura aucun effet même sur les
jeunes alors sur les études australienne
ça montre que ça n'incite pas non plus
au marché noir sert ya pas plus de
d'achats illicites de tabac depuis cette
mesure et que d'autre part les fumeurs
qui continuent à fumer continuent à
s'approvisionner chez leur détaillant en
australie au moins il n'y a pas eu
d'impact sur les ventes chez les
buralistes
ça a diminué le nombre de tables de
fumeurs quand même notamment chez les
jeunes
mais ceux qui continuent à fumer
continuent à s'approvisionner chez leur
buraliste 2012 en australie
2015 dans les pays scandinaves et c'est
l'irlande et l'angleterre aussi norvège
aussi dites moi pourquoi seulement en
2016 en france
c'est probablement c'est dès l'aube ils
sont forts ici c'est je pense que
probablement assez complexe à je ne sais
pas pourquoi ça mis autant de temps en
tout cas les les associations de lutte
contre le tabac la société française de
tabacologie
le comité national de lutte contre le
tabagisme eux étaient favorables à cette
mesure depuis bien longtemps mais
effectivement elle a mis du temps à être
mises en place je pense parce que
notamment les buralistes c'était un
petit peu opposés à cette mesure qui
craignant beaucoup qu'il perte une part
de marché importante
alors maintenant tous les paquets ils
sont de couleur noire avec des photos à
ces chocs ces photos on en avait déjà
certaine sur certains paquets est-ce que
ça en effet c'est à dire qu'ils sont
nettement plus visible sur un fond noir
que lorsqu'il y avait voilà ça montre si
les études ont montré que ça faisait
prendre conscience aussi aux fumeurs de
façon plus importante même s'ils savent
que c'est mauvais de l'impact vraiment
négatif sur la santé du tabac chez les
jeunes c'est vraiment pas ça me fera
beaucoup moins style de fumée est de
sortir ces paquets
avec ces photos qui sont quand même
relativement choc
je pense qu'il y aura un impact moindre
des photos choc chez les jeunes qui sont
habitués à d'autres images chocs
on voit aussi habité les buralistes dix
personnes font enfin certains disent que
ça ne va pas fonctionner mais un de
leurs arguments c'est que maintenant
avec ce paquet qui est noir est juste la
photo choc
il n'y a plus en fait toutes les
annotations qui était marqué sur le taux
de goudron par exemple est-ce que c'est
dommage d'avoir perdu tout non parce que
ces taux de goudron en fait était
souvent difficile à comprendre pour les
fumeurs c'est ce sont des taux qui sont
calculées dans la fumée à part une
machine à fumée
donc ce sont absolument pas les taux de
goudron de nicotine et monoxyde de
carbone sont contenues dans le paquet
pour une fois de la cigarette est fumée
et les fumeurs ne fume pas comme cette
machine donc forcément ils ont souvent
des taux différents selon la manière
dont il fut donc à mon avis ça c'est pas
très important
ce qui est sûr c'est que ces images
montres et même le paquet de couleur
neutre en australie ça prouver que les
fumeurs du coup même si c'est les mêmes
cigarettes de dans les trouvais moins
bonne moins appétissante
donc ils avaient moins envie de fumer
parce que le pecq le packaging compte
beaucoup aussi dans le goût et ça déjà
été aussi prouver pour certains aliments
qui était qui en est emballé dans
notamment des gâteaux qui entend emballé
dans le packaging différent et testée
par plusieurs consommateurs trouver ce
dont le packaging était beaucoup moins
glamour moins bon et bien je vous
remercie pour toutes ces informations on
va passer maintenant un tout autre sujet
on reste sur la thématique de la santé
après des fêtes de fin d'année avec des
repas assez copieux pour beaucoup moi
aussi d'ailleurs beaucoup d'entre vous
souhaitent débuter cette année emplettes
en pleine forme
nous recevons donc frederick henderson
coach sportif saint quentinois pour les
conseils detox
bonsoir personne ne soit vous êtes coach
sportif mais aussi préparateur physique
et entraîneur des templiers d'elancourt
entre autres effectivement si on alors
j'ai beaucoup mangé je voue beaucoup
aussi
parfois il faut que je débute mais repas
pour cette année 2010 est je pense que
la première chose à apprendre en compte
c'est que quand on beaucoup de personnes
qui vont partir sur un régime avec
l'idée ils vont se mettre au régime et
puis au bout de quelques semaines s'ils
ont perdu les kilos en trop et ils vont
s'arrêter
le problème c'est que manger
correctement c'est pas c'est pas la
sphère de quelques semaines c'est une
habitude à développer et entretenir tout
au long de l'année pour qu'on se
retrouve pas à tous les nouvelles ans ou
à chaque pas d'excès à va devoir refaire
un nouveau régime parce que ce qui va se
passer c'est que dès qu'on arrête de
manger correctement on va prendre des
kilos en plus
on va faire son régime moi perdre les
kilos en trop et puis dès que ça
s'arrête on va retourner à ses mauvaises
habitudes et tous les kilos perdus vont
venir donc je pense que le but des
personnes c'est de perdre les kilos en
trop pour de bon la meilleure façon
c'est jamais s'arrêter de manger
correctement
donc techniquement la meilleure solution
c'est déjà commencer par manger beaucoup
de légumes assez beaucoup de légumes
beaucoup de légumes déjà pas du moment
on mange beaucoup de légumes on récupère
toutes les vitamines qui sont à
l'intérieur toutes les fibres
alimentaires au niveau de la digestion
et plus de la flore intestinale sa part
mes deux tours et équilibrée il n'y a
pas besoin de produits magiques ou de
poudre ou deux je ne sais quoi des
toques la juste besoin de manger
correctement des vrais aliments cuisinés
de quelle manière les légumes un des
défis en fait des régimes s'il arrivait
à suivre son alimentation
ce qui a le plus de goût pour nous à la
limite une des astuces des les plus
pratiques c'est utiliser les épices si
vous aimez maître du poivre du sel
roulerait un peu le goût des légumes
quand on en sait un peu fade
ça peut être une bonne solution celle
avec modération quand même oui après je
peux avoir la main lourde
bah en fait après l avantage des légumes
c'est que ces gorgé d'eau donc là le
plus petit surplus de sel va être
compensé en partie par par l'eau après
si on n'a pas de soucis liés à
l'hypertension et et à l'excès de sel
roman semble pas être un souci surtout
si on se concentre sur des aliments non
transformés si vous achetez les légumes
et pour les cuisiner vous même il n'y a
pas tout ce processus de transformation
industrielle où il rajoute beaucoup de
sucre où beaucoup de sel pour réhausser
le goût ça vous êtes en charge de le
faire vous-même donc au final c'est
peut-être mieux de le faire soi-même que
de confier à apprendre des plats déjà
cuisinés et donc les légumes
ok c'est de composer mon repas est ce
que j'ai toujours droit de la viande ou
ça sera plus d allant croissant le
deuxième aspect vraiment important des
régimes hypocaloriques donc pour perdre
du poids c'est la protéine parce qu'en
fait le le fait d'être en hypokhâgne
manque de calories qu'on a dans son
assiette parce qu'on mange un peu moins
ça entraîne ça entraîne des besoins en
protéines qui sont augmentés donc il
faut continuer à manger beaucoup de
viande pendant pas forcément de l'avion
dans le monde l'important c'est
diversifié ses apports de protéines donc
on peut retrouver de la protéine dans
les oeufs dans les produits laitiers
on peut trouver la protéine pas dans la
viande le poulet le poisson aussi des
sources végétales qui compte aussi comme
delà de la protéine les produits à base
de soja de kinois aussi qu'ils sont
assez à la mode tout ce qui est
légumineuses les lentilles les
et haricots rouges tout ce genre tout ce
genre d'aliments là c'est une bonne
source de protéines et de films et c'est
vraiment c'est vrai c'est vraiment des
bons aliments pour doit intégrer dans
son régime alimentaire
parce qu'un des gros risque en fait du
des régimes hypocaloriques c'est la
perte de masse musculaire une
dépassement de mitiger la perte des
muscles c'est de manger assez de
protéines
parce que le point que sexy a pas assez
de protéines dans l'alimentation
le corps va les chercher dans les seules
réserves qui peut avoir et ce sont les
muscles points 2/2 sais que c'est pas
censé être des réserves de deux
protéines saison c'est servir à se
dépasser à faire du sport d'accord donc
ça ça peut être une
c'est le deuxième gros points manger
beaucoup de légumes à cette protéine
boire beaucoup d'eau limiter tout ce qui
est apport en calories liquides mérite
tout ce qu'il boit son sucre et les
armes on oublie même les jus de fruits
parce qu'elle limite vous prenez un
verre de jus de fruit de 30 centimes
c'est pas grand chose à l'intérieur il y
aura déjà 3 4 3 4 orange ces éléments je
lui ai de déboires manger 4 oranges
c'est autre chose que des bras c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué en plus pour les
éplucher et c'est donc ça peut être une
autre astuce plutôt que de boire du jus
de fruits ou de manger les fruits vous
buvez le verre d'eau à côté
ou sinon vous diluez votre votre verre
de jus tribute à moitié fruits moitié
eau et et ça ça permet de réduire de
moitié la peau rang en calories tout en
maintenant une bonne hydratation c'est
toujours très important
ok ok nombre vous m'avez changer mon
attention c'est pas grave c'est pas
grave on va passer maintenant au sport
parce que c'est souvent l'une des
résolutions vous foncez dans les salles
de sport alors j'imagine qu'il ya
plusieurs cas pour ceux qui ne faisaient
plus du tout de ce sport pour ceux qui
ont besoin d'un petit peu plus qu'on
laissait tomber
qu est ce par quoi il faut recommencer
ce qu'ils font c'est aussi des
règlements là sa mère je devrais faire
c'est d'aller voir son auteur dans une
visite médicale un check up pour être
sûr qu'il n'y a pas de problème si
jamais un moindre problème - le docteur
pourra vous dire ce que vous pouvez ce
que vous pouvez pas faire après un truc
qui est pas mal à la mode c'est ils se
mettent les gens se mettent des défis de
cette année je vais courir un
demi-marathon découvrir temps et en or
faut faire attention je crois au mort
subite par exemple qui peuvent arriver
si on veut pas voir le médecin ça ça
peut arriver après c'est aussi le
problème de passer de 0 à 100 c on passe
de
d'un style de vie on a passé longtemps
sur son canapé on a pas du tout de faire
du sport
et puis tout à coup on se met à courir
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup et en fait ce
qui va se passer donc dans le meilleur
des cas on va avoir une tendinite
déjà c'est pas terrible mais pas mais si
on a une tendinite on va devoir aller
voir le docteur ont fais de la kiné et
pendant ce temps là on fait plus de
sport
donc c'est déjà raté après les des vrais
risques parle de fracture de fatigue
il ya des gens qui comparaît but de
faire du sport qui se met à faire
beaucoup de sport d'un coup et le
problème c'est qu'il faut du temps pour
que les ligaments les hausses seraient
adaptés à faire l'effort à l'effort et
ce qui peut leur arriver c'est les
fractures de fatigue c'est parra que des
docteurs me raconte qu' il ya une dame
qui était plein de bonnes intentions
très motivés qu'ils clive qui voulaient
s'y remettre et puis elle se met à
courir à couvrir des tous les week-ends
1h 2h et au bout d'un ou deux mois
fracture fracture de fatigue au tibia et
prom d'une fracture s'exclama pour
plusieurs mois de convalescence donc ça
des faits un peu face avant un pas en
compte l'objectif qu'on avait quoi donc
ce qui est vraiment important quand on
reprend le sport c'est d'y aller
progressivement
donc si vous faites j'ai rien du tout et
que vous voulez faire un demi marathon
c'est peut-être plus tôt là la
résolution 2018 que celle de 2017
mais en termes d'exercice pas la peine
de prendre des gros poids directement à
comme je vous dis progressivement faux
faux faux faux ce qu'on met dans le bain
adsl on peut aussi
après faut trouver une activité qui nous
plaît parce que si ça nous plaît pas on
va vite on va vite se lasser on va
laisser tomber
donc le but c'est quand même de
s'inscrire dans la durée surtout que
c'est important à long terme le sport
parce que c'est un effet positif sur la
masse osseuse donc surtout pour les
femmes et risque d'ostéoporose sont
réduits en faisant souvent du sport plus
jeunes dans leur vie il ya aussi les
problèmes d'arthrose qui sont convoi que
parcourir de temps en temps même chez
les gens qui ont l'air trop ça améliore
les symptômes de douleur etc pour la
gestion du stress aussi c'est important
de courir longtemps et c'est donc c'est
vrai que faire du sport en s'y remettent
progressivement
et puis le après ça dépend aussi des
guides et des personnes ainsi
institutions souffrent d'obésité savoir
que l'obésité c'est pas juste une
histoire de goût on a trop mangé c'est
une vraie maladie
mon plat fou quand même allé consulter
un spécialiste en nutrition 6 et de
l'obésité un docteur nutritionniste
plutôt qu'un diététiciens même si vous
utilisez un peu si c'est un bon dj
titien et peut très bien
d aller chercher de l'aide
professionnelle parce que c'est vraiment
quelque chose de compliqué pendant qu'à
de l'obésité c'est vraiment une maladie
très complexe il faut avoir vraiment des
conseils de qualité
après prendre quand on est en surpoids
et si on se remet à courir il faut
savoir que quand on court chaque impact
à chaque impact avec le sol s'est
plusieurs fois son propre poids de corps
donc chez quelqu'un qui en oui chez
quelqu un qu en bonne santé ce n'est pas
un souci
mais pour quelqu'un en surpoids ça va
mettre trop de stress sur les eaux et
sur les articulations et si on arrive
ici le taux le corps n'a pas le temps de
s'adapter
il va casser eh bien merci pour toutes
ces informations normalement tout le
monde devrait pouvoir reprendre le sport
assez tout doucement progressive
progressivement et manger correctement
grâce à vous merci en tout cas à vous
deux c'est la fin de ce set 8 les
invités bonne soirée à tous et aussi
bonne année
[Musique]